moi j'espère je peux pas vous mettre en
boîte 6 il faut nous mettre en boîte
parce que un homme averti en vaut deux
ok et là on a parlé beaucoup de rongeurs
staller le moustique tigre voilà on en
fait tous les jours c'est quoi c'est qui
concrètement ça ressemble à un tig parce
que ces tigres src ya des rayures
blanches il est plus petit qu'un
moustique classique il fait maximum 5 mm
l'accord qu'elle a des rayures blanches
et noires comme le pied ou comme le
groupe seb voilà il est rapide et commun
comme un tigre genre quoi il est très
rapide très rapide et je pense que là il
est plus rapide que nous tenons sur ses
vrais monstres y courent plus vite
comment
faire
avec on le voit on le voit à l'écran il
est vraiment il est impressionnant et
surtout il a une particularité c'est
qu'il va piquer la journée n'ont donc ce
genre comme ça on est tranquille en
journée le mas en train le matin en
train de prendre son café ou le soir à
l'apéro autant que la mort à papa nous
les la piscine abîme d'un moustique
tigre ouais c et il a peur il a peur de
quoi et bah alors justement de typique
on le sent tout de suite ce que
contrairement aux autres moustiques sont
bons sans une douleur à voir rouge ça va
on le sent tout de suite et donc il peut
cliquer partout ouais il peut piquer
partout ils piquent partout donc là dans
toutes les régions forêt baobab le
couvert en fac toile donc beau mot sert
donc je vais à la piscine en doudoune
l'année prochaine voilà
ce que ça fait grossir la partie piquer
un raidissement dans la foule
qui se dit concentré connais pas je vous
l'avais dit c'est un con
voilà
ouais c'est sérieux la santé avec ça
nous prend très sérieux en france
effectivement ça fait plus peur qu un
tiercé 800000 ce que j'ai mis les mm et
aux huit cent mille morts par an des
moustiques nos statuts beaucoup mais on
nous a cassé les couilles avec le comité
à tuchan fois plus de moustiques c'est
combien non mais silencieux non plus à
un vaccin
at en 2000 avec les vaccins en rien les
mois à venir à la palombe à qui va
arriver on doit
y avoir dans deux ans vous allez faire
avec ça toute la journée tu es tu parles
hfr le vaccin pour le moustique tigre
tu fais le max pour
l'abeille de l'abbé tueuse
faisait des vacances pas déconner tu as
fait tes vacances y aura débat des
balles par des parraineurs c'est bon il
ya quoi y'a des rhinocéros et chevaux
voilà sinon c'est un maxi moi je peux y
aller je peux aller dans la mare après l
on pourrait donc donc là dit il arrive
et donc serait silencieuse ça pique
alors généralement les légendes d'appels
depuis quelques jours tous les jours on
soit 500 à nantes pendant serais ravi
plus d'un week end et qu'un point rouge
une piqûre les gens ils pensent quoi il
pense tout de suite au moustique tigre
ouais souvent c'est il ya beaucoup de
punaises de lit il faut savoir enfin
brune est devenue la plupart du temps
quand on est à plus de 90% du café c'est
des punaises de lit radicaux alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors déjà on va à
paris les punaises de lit bas c'est
important ouais la punaise de lit
ma chambre j'ai mis la main sur moi en
commun c'est quoi la punaise de lit
alors c'est une petite heure et c'est
une petite bête mais qui est
généralement dans le lit ok et à la
sortir la nuit las le seul point commun
entre la punaise et le moustique tigre
c'est qu'ils reconnaissent le corps
humain grâce au dioxyde de carbone ouais
voilà moi j'en venais pas qu'en général
les dégâts des gens qui émettent plus
que d'autres et donc à ouais mais c'est
quoi si ce qui m'arrive un jour je te
jure que c'est vrai je vais dans l'hôtel
je dors avec un copain à moi que
j'embrasse giroud se reconnaîtra on dort
à côté en demi on mange pas de ce pain
là
mais ce sont les questions d'économie
jetant qu'il veut ric-rac on a dormi
ensemble gollnisch d'un hôtel à
deauville
c'est un tournoi de poker on aura côté
bimbo je suis dit voilà comment ils
arrivent ils guettent je me bats les
couilles je
dis quand il bat les couilles brad wall
etienne marseille
[Rires]
non mais antoine s'était trompé à
brossard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hélas
hélas hélas hélas le matin sera à
l'écouté moi je me lève normal et lui
sans régler sur élevé mais il était tout
un piquet de partout on a dormi dans le
même et vous êtes pieds nus ou habillés
way
en cas de son caleçon s'accordent à dire
ce qu ils étaient tous mais ça rigolait
il est sorti avec des piqûres de partout
sur le corps moi j'avais pas une piqûre
alors je dis frère malheureusement c'est
la faute à pas de chance on peut être
dans un lit pique une personne pas
l'autre moi c'est un mec piqué on n'a
pas de trace et au contraire ils sont
hyper allergies qui ont des gros cela
parle 200 sucré ou pas en fait c'est ça
s'est passé
ils reconnaissent le corps humain par le
pad sont sucrés ou salés à péage qui
convient pas au pin et ouais je sais 200
m une étudiante s'est uni jeudi vais
parce que j'aurais parlé à mon art
asiatique mois touché troqué
sa prochaine fois vous allez à l'hôtel
faut toujours vérifier le matelas vous
saouler le matelas ou vérifier ce à quoi
donne et on les voit les poneys seront
qu'elles ont quelque peu pas toujours
mais ce qu'on est des gros surf et
station vous soulevez le matelas vous
allez voir
c'est leurs excréments ou des traces de
sang ouais souvent les écrase après
qu'elle faisait là bas moi et moi et moi
je vais me souviens l'autre j'ai vu des
traces de sang voilà quand y avait eu un
meurtre
à toi ça c'est intéressant ça c'est très
fort ça donc tu soulèves parce que moi
alors les punaises de lit c'est grave si
on se fait piquer par le maître de
niveau c'est embêtant c'est gênant c'est
pas très beau mais il n'y a pas de
risque savaria pas d'un moustique tir où
on peut vraiment alors justement
revenons sur le moustique tigre le
moustique qui joue rappelle 67
départements en vigilance accrue sur le
moustique le moustique tigre il vient
d'où déjà il vient d'asie du sud-est et
amazigh à nessakh pic alors donc en 2004
il ya eu 5 l'import-export que le
moustique tigre là pendant cinquante
kilomètres en train de voler rif et 50 m
100 m un accord qui vient avec le bateau
le train j'aurais dialoguer avec ses
bagages
le gall décollage le gall en asie du sud
est les quitte sa famille paille tu vas
où je pars en europe
je vais piquer en europe j'ai trouvé ce
matin danone alger ne
doit pas recommencer je pars dans le
loiret maman ne donnait pas une jolie
est arrivée c'est vrai c'est un truc de
fou alors donc il part il arrive en 2004
en europe hors uk a pris le bateau et la
tupina c'était violent il ya des
rapports de pneus d'occasion c'est là
aussi qu'il arrive la première fois il
était cité une bonne année goodyear pour
les
ai donc pas et donc il est arrivé on
arrivé depuis 2004 ça arrive en france
et sa soeur au départ c'est uniquement
dans le sud est maintenant ses 64
départements qui sont en france on se
sent bien en europe ils sont à ce qu'est
ce que c'est dû au climat qui fait mon
cochon maintenant sa sage ou missile il
s'adapte en fait c'est un peu comme le
comique qui s'adapte un but partout à
sceller les moustiques ils se sont
adaptés à tous les documents dont contre
locaux vides le moustique tigre daniel
moreau
ce ne serait pas la fin de l'humanité je
pose la question sarko quand on est
piqué en fait si vous êtes piqué en
journée hop vous allez chercher à bisser
petit dongle urgence des dix minutes
pour pour désinfecter pas pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe sinon parce que
sinon il peut y avoir des complications
surtout qu'elles compliquaient pas le
risque c'est quoi c'est que s'ils
appliquaient part de quelqu'un à cas la
dengue juste avant ouais quelqu'un qui
vous dit que vous récupérez latin de ouf
voilà j'en reviens pas la voile et du
coup c'est le risque il est là enfin là
bien que c'est quoi la dengue cercle
il ya 400 le ben ouais il ya 400
millions de l'occiput quelqu'un cas la
dengue il faut que nos fidèles à dingue
oui c'est très dangereux pour les femmes
enceintes ans et sa musique est arrivé
le premier classique à quelques années
les moustiques tigres voilà le plus beau
coup il a fait un gros danger pour les
femmes enceintes donc forcément il faut
prendre des précautions quand j'en crois
qu'il faut acheter doctor vous avez dit
à la bbc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en france
oui mais la pâte et qu'on voit il a
lancé jean menacer sa
matinale à 9,6 inaltérée n'en a pas pas
dix minutes mais ce qu'il faut faire
mais la chose numéro un s'il ya une
chose à retenir ce soir c'est parce que
par exemple qu'on dédé desjardins sur
deux choses il faut braquer d'eau
stagnante oui à l'accord par exemple
dans un outil dans un bocal dans la
gouttière dans son abri cinéma ici si
vous battez vous mâcher et un jacuzzi
oui autre est chaude en attendant avait
semblé donc si vous voyagez pas qu'on ne
vous amusez pas aller retirer vous même
vous a plu aussi comment ça va chercher
dans mon cerveau machine
sociale professionnelle mais par contre
aux prêts à graça chapelle quelqu'un
le chlore maintenant
la randonnée des mares d une piscine
abandonné
attention aussi bondir au pot de fleurs
dans les bras des domaines relatifs à la
chaux 14 ya des moustiques tigres c'est
la dame qui s'occupe des moustiques
tigres dans le sud oui pas chez la
piscine et l'a dit un gars dans mon
émission
vous êtes en train de regarder sont
bâchées la piscine sheila
hachez la lampe il
va tomber une barre merci il ya des
moustiques tigres et à la maison
c'est des machines à qu'on a misé
marque ça sent les moustiques d'y
ajouter une machine
mais rassurez vous c'est bon j'ai pas
trop de moustiques tigres jusqu'à ce que
le moustique sur vire sur lot a
justement fait les tu crois que j'ai
fait un moustique en jet ski
les falafels vont pondre leurs oeufs sur
les sur l'eau stagnante c'est ça aussi
ah bon parce que j'ai vraiment cessé des
femmes pour leur
effet les femmes moustique tigre qui
vont nous piquer en fait ah ouais
moi moi j'aimerais savoir ce qu'on peut
faire contre l'équipe jusque là c'est
très important ici et c'est très grave
et à clément guérin h éric - kindy le
basilic savoir jusqu'à la basilique
saint-marc franchement aller on dit
ouais les huiles essentielles et tout ça
il ya deux choses vous avez serré que si
la machine
thomas
jobin la basilique ça t'a coûté 2 balles
leur exemple par contre si vous avez la
climatisation chez vous dans le sud il a
beaucoup qui longe le fleuve est
tranquille mais les moustiques n'aiment
pas ça asseyez-vous manger en terrasse
c'est ça bonjour docteur rumack
ventilateur vous êtes tranquille
d'accord mais alors par exemple vous et
s'il ya une personne qui vous fait du
vent
mais non mais dites moi en tout cas il
faut mettre des vêtements plutôt clair
donc par exemple faut pas s'habiller
comme ça cela dit j'aime bien il aime
bien les couleurs foncées lewin a alors
les moustiques aime les gens mal habillé
des vêtements amples et qui recouvre
bien piquionne tu attends beaucoup de
repiquer non mais sérieux mais c'est
vrai donc c'est ça ouais mais attends
quand on a la plage quand tu veux mettre
des vêtements amples des mois la moelle
moi j'y vais j'y vais en string ouais
enfin senti une cause que les répulsifs
samoussas malama répulsifs et répressive
de corps marche aussi marche bien et aux
prises les prix ça marche plutôt bien
mais en fait tout marche à la
citronnelle aussi voilà exactement de
repos ne faut pas oublier des choses
avant les repousser et par contre au
public le moustique tigre il va voler à
50 cents mètres au-dessus de la petite
mare de dugny en fait il va pas faire un
kilomètre pour aller vous chercher donc
si vous vérifiez mercher vous qui a
passé de cette eau stagnante franchement
vous êtes tranquilles voilà après si
jamais vous en voyez vous avez une
société comme comme éradique d'accord
ben si mal merci donc là vous arrivez ou
mais voilà vous faites le nécessaire
voilà on a alors souvent fait une
nébulisation on le fait pas on fait une
égalisation une fumigation si un bâton
on propage du produit par ailleurs je
donne un exemple l'année dernière il ya
un grand si complexe sim de cinéma en
ile de france n'est pas catherine
s'appelle-t-il et de canalisations qu'à
sauter dans le vide sanitaire la boum
moustique tigre de partout et on se fait
piquer dans le cinéma non à l'appel en
urgence on intervient et là on est bue
lisons mais des produits partout et on
ne résout le problème est surtout faut
pas essayer soi même quand c'est qu'on
ya un gros cas comme ça encore
incroyable et moi je pense que moi
j'aime bien les gens aiment bien mais
parfois je fais des opérations ou petit
fils adore ben je vous enverrai la
prochaine fois les défenses
alalala et là mon fils me prend pour
héros on peut les rattraper les
boutiques en plein vol stationnaire il
convaincra j'aurais pris comme ça je
sais pas je suis titre
bon ben si c'est hanouna
pour tous regarde moi dans les yeux tu
vois les piquets
ça va rattraper un jour c'est jour de
kippour je dis aujourd'hui tous les
juifs lui pardonne aux moustiques qui
les ont piqué
tous les juifs sauf l'oie je pardonne
pas
[Applaudissements]
ce débat il faut forcément le tuer ce
moment tant que militant vegan
côté des répulsifs ses skis répulsif sur
le corps se déplie extérieur de
l'éloigner ça va ça va vous avez pas le
tuer mais il est impliqué quelqu'un
d'autre quand et quels sont les symboles
est ce qu'on peut dire aux musiques du
parler lui dire non pas moi l'autre
est ce que est ce que le moustique
comprendre
non mais je crois qu'il ya pas pire
qu'un accident mais c'est que je crois
que c'est le pire truc monde j'arrête de
dormir je crois que ça m'arrivait un
jour je dormais y avait un moustique et
passe à côté moi je me suis levée et là
j'ai mis tout l'attirail c'est quoi
l'intérêt oui l'essentiel basilique
tomates cerises et je suis parti à la
recherche non mais ça c'est pas
moustique tigre la nuit d'accord on est
à le moustique et que la journée la nuit
il fait quoi il est chaud pose comme en
hiver il saura qu'il sort beaucoup tous
bords y paraît
à quel moment on se dit que ça la piqûre
a dégénéré qu'il faut aller aux urgences
à leur accord bah c'est vrai ça c'est un
fantôme qu'est ce que c'est vrai qu'au
bout de 3 entre 3 et 7 jours vous allez
voir des symptômes qui ressemble un peu
à la grippe où cohabitent faudrait que
les mêmes cinq hommes de les voir la
fière des éruptions cutanées des plaques
rouges vous en fais pas bien quoi et là
vous pouvez d'enquêté allait voir un
médecin homéopathe d'accord donc est il
pas on peut attraper le chikungunya sap
on peut attraper aussi bien sûr que
c'est la fièvre jaune paludisme tout ça
le moustique tigre je vais dire c'est le
moustique ses yeux le 1er avril ont de
la fièvre jaune c'est quand on est cocu
et vacciner quand j'avais
donc voilà donc et donc qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire et à mme lauria ces machines
qui coûtent cher ça émet du dioxyde de
carbone des animaux barcelone humains
ils vont savoir si un humain il est
exactement celle des machines watson
humain il s'approche mais là tu leur en
avait une de machines comme sur chaque
pièce
alors ça se bat à l'extérieur 1 oui ça
dépend de l'extérieur de ces voix là
après si je vous dis 6 en intérieur vous
avez un nid là il faut pas faut pas
rigoler vous appelez une société à nice
et on peut pas y aller enfin attention
parce que sinon vous allez considérer le
poids qu'ils peuvent pas vraiment
attaquer ah ouais faut faire attention
mais attention pour moi avec toi je vais
défoncer vous savez que le pic ces
femmes et début juin
et nos pics de ta connerie et là on veut
voir éclore c'est pas vrai a été prêté
jusqu'à la fin de la période et vous
allez voir que ses fins mais quel est le
match de clôture va arriver donc là on a
encore quelques quelques semaines pour
se préparer et j'adorais cette sanction
de mike brant et la mèche médias qu'une
larve dans tes yeux
la chine couvre combien de superficie
alors ça dépend du prix de la machine
ouais mais généralement c'est plusieurs
centaines de mètres carrés quoi il a dit
ça va raconter
ses gaffes à taylor plus à la clim de
tranquille partout dans toutes vos
pièces d'or il a pas là qui me regardent
et c'est pas mal hein c'est pas mal
jacqueline c'est bien c'est pas mal
c'est très sympa l'axé mais les
moustiquaires c'est plus écolo allez me
voir faire ça marche très bien avec la
web bonne idée ça me va très bien c'est
l'été des moustiquaires sur les fenêtres
vous avez peur ah ouais ça marche mais
moussa faire virer de salaire en moins
cher bah oui on vous fait un bon prix
aussi non c'est vrai ils sont tous quant
au look et vous fait lire à l'aller
allez aujourd'hui clapas excellent on
fait tous les jours c'est un grand
talent comme on est sur les rats
lancement
enfin j'ai pas vous raconter si vous
avez pu aller au restaurant calaisis bar
à côté de civils quand il dit que ça
remonte par les tuyaux des voix c'est
parce que ça bouge
est-ce que les rares au monde par les
tuyaux des toilettes il faut que ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est une souris
une souris ça rend dans un trou de
stylos d'accord dans un trou si haute
saône c'est tout petit ça sera au tour
des canalisations donc ça peut rentrer
ça remonte par les canalisations il a
raison maintenant mais moi j'ai voilà
votre cas je n'ai pas encore entendu
ma tante encore ça arrive à sa tante
aussi on voit coiffés en arrière c'est
sa série gossip est pas drôle mais oui
atteint ou pata lui-même raconte en
arrière
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est cadeau
les rails par rapport aux moustiques ils
sont très intelligents ouais faut ruser
à l'homme aux 6 5 mais vous vous allez
tirer une petite bouteille d'eau
chronique heures alors
moi aussi qu'il est tombé le style oral
qu'est ce qui se passe au niveau des
rares en ce moment en france gens ne
savent pas faut savoir qu'il ya un an
par exemple en ile de france il ya trois
fois plus de rats que d'habitants dans
tout paris parce que youtube et les
travaux dans votre rue sega fin vous
êtes sûr vous l'avez vous appris à le
remonter si un restaurant en bas de chez
vous une super une supérette l'épicerie
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de rongeurs moi
j'ai reçu c'est dans mon immeuble ils
ont mis une petite un petit circulaire
pour expliquer qu'il y avait des rats
qui était montée jusqu'au premier étage
même au dernier est arrivé dans tous les
sens tu as quoi c'est parce que c'est
les poubelles des caves c'est qu'au
départ c'est je vous dis là l'immeuble
être infesté parce qu'il ya une raison
il m a tiré soit parce que c'est un
problème d'hygiène soit parce qu'un
restaurant il ya une boulangerie des
travaux et après ça monte à tous les
étages et ça et si on traite pas ça fait
ça se reproduit très vite toutes les
cinq semaines une portée à t5 semaine
portera
vous savez dans les restaurants il y en
a beaucoup énormément énormément les
restaurants ont un contrat obligatoire
de dératisation parce que
et là c'est la gamelle
moi c'était à gauche l'a
apparemment il ya daniel
oui l'autre jour je marchais le soir
tard sur le boulevard sébastopol à paris
j'ai été précédée par plusieurs rats
après tout reconnu j'ai voulu perdre et
c'est le film
est écrit le père m'a dit que j'avais de
moins en moins peur roche est de plus en
plus des hommes de coeur marché autour
des actions leur jeter de la nourriture
et de peur vous vous en doutez fait pour
fait que on va voir beaucoup autour des
quais par exemple et les rats
aujourd'hui dans tous les restaurants à
tous quoi tout ça il ya des rongeurs par
tous appris à des restaurateurs qui sont
sérieux qui vont prendre les sociétés
sérieuses comme l'un d'eux qu'ils vont
traiter régulièrement d'autres qui sont
un peu moins sérieux donc moi je vous
donner un conseil comme d'alloresto vous
allez vous allez aux toilettes ouais oui
si c'est propre en général un
restaurateur qui est ce qu a lyon vers
son établissement il y aura des
toilettes propres il aura consentiront
j'aimerais si c'est dégueulasse vous
pouvez voir ça mais c'est sûr que là il
ya des rongeurs
dont j'ai lu on fait quoi qui sauront y
avait des rats dans la salle principale
est donc appelée la serveuse lui même à
dahiyah drm a dit bah oui c'est comme ça
maintenant il ya des gamins répondre aux
enjeux quoi c'est comme ça ouais mais je
suis resté quand même il ya beaucoup de
restos avec des pigeons aussi avec des
bijoux à l'intérieur
vous êtes juste aller au restaurant et
gilles verdez
tout simplement ça n'a rien à voir